- Hello. Hello, everyone.
I am Kaveh Khoshnood.
I'm gonna start with a brief introduction
before I pass it over to my
colleague Dr. Anees Chagpar
for her presentation.
I am a faculty at the Yale
School of Public Health,
and I am the faculty director
for Humanitarian Research Lab
with a particular interest
to address the health
of populations that are
affected by humanitarian crisis,
including armed conflict.
I've had a focus on the MENA region,
the Middle East, North Africa region.
My own training is in
infection disease epidemiology,
but every time I speak with
humanitarian organizations,
the NCDs, noncommunicable
diseases, come up,
and cancer, cancer care and treatment,
has come up multiple times
when I have visited
these humanitarian NGOs.
And I recall, it was kind
of a disturbing story.
When I visited Lebanon,
and I went to a humanitarian organization.
There was a Syrian oncologist
who had been displaced into Lebanon,
and he has started the mammography clinic
for Syrian refugees.
I think he was the only one doing that,
and he been screening
women for breast cancer.
He told me that one of these women had
early-stage breast cancer,
and they referred her to a UN agencies
that provide financial
support for cancer treatment,
and they told this woman that,
"You're very early-stage breast cancer.
We cannot fund you.
Come back," whatever year later or so.
"If your breast cancer is advanced,
then we can provide support for you."
That was such a disturbing
story that I heard.
It's completely sort of
anti-public health issue
because we're supposed
to be able to screen
and treat breast cancer
patient as early as possible,
not wait, but these UN agencies
have very limited funds.
They make these decision about people
who are in late-stage breast cancer,
are likely to die, they
kind of focus on them
the limited resources that they have.
So I was very disturbed by that,
and I was trying to
figure out what I can do
to support this project.
I ended up working with one
of our students long ago named Jude Alawa
who comes from a Syrian family background.
He ended up doing the first study looking
at cancer awareness
and access to treatment
for cancer patients in Lebanon,
both in the Syrian refugee population
and the Lebanese population.
That was a very sort of
meaningful study that he did,
and it triggered conversation
about different stakeholders
to continue this work.
I then learned that our
colleagues called SAMS,
Syrian American Medical Society,
had launched a clinic,
an oncology clinic in
2018 in northwest Syria,
which, as you may know,
it's a conflict zone.
Northwest Syria is not
under government control,
and SAMS, Syrian American Medical Society,
is one of the few organizations
that was able to provide
care and treatment,
and they actually had set up a clinic
to take care of cancer patients.
So I reached out to
them to see what support
we can provide to them,
and what they wanted was
they had been collecting a lot of data,
but they really hadn't had the time
and capacity to finalize this data.
They wanted us to support
then and put out reports.
I reached out to my
colleague Dr. Anees Chagpar,
who's a wonderful surgeon,
oncologist, and I asked
whether she would be interested
in participating in this project.
She said yes, she applied for the grant,
it's from the MacMillan Center,
and was able to launch the study
that she's gonna tell you about.
Just briefly, I'm gonna mention to you,
Dr. Anees Chagpar is a full professor
in the Department of Surgery
at the Yale School of Medicine.
She has specific expertise
in breast cancer.
As you can see, she has
multiple master degree
in addition to her medical degree.
She has a masters in public health.
She has a masters in bioethics
and medical humanities.
She has an MBA from Yale.
And she's also a fantastic communicator.
You may have come across
her Coursera course
on breast cancer, which
is extremely popular.
She's quite active on social media,
and she's very passionate
about global health
and leadership and academic training.
I'm really delighted that she
agreed to lead this project,
and today she's gonna present to you
where this project has gone
over the last two years.
Dr. Chagpar, I'll pass it on to you.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much, Kaveh.
So it's a real pleasure to be here
to present this work.
This, as Kaveh mentioned,
was a collaborative effort
between the School of Medicine,
the School of Public Health,
as well as our colleagues
from around the world
through the Syrian
American Medical Society.
It was really a
mixed-methods investigation
into the experiences
and outcomes of patients
with breast cancer in the SAMS clinic
in northwest Syria.
So before we dive in,
here are my disclosures.
The ones at the top really
will not be relevant
to today's discussion.
I'm not going to be discussing anything
that is pertinent to
those funding sources,
but I do want to highlight,
as Kaveh mentioned,
that the work that I'll
be presenting was funded
in part by the Yale MacMillan
Center, Program on Refugees,
Forced Displacement, and
Humanitarian Response,
and we are very grateful for that support.
So if we take a step back
and we think about the Syrian conflict,
this has really been going on since 2011,
and it started as a
civilian uprising rooted
in the Arab Spring.
We know that this really
took on an armed conflict
and involved targeted strikes,
particularly on healthcare
personnel and facilities.
It caused over 400,000 deaths,
and there was more than
5.6 million refugees
out of the pre-war
population of 22 million.
That 5.6 million is
likely an underestimate.
And World Health Organization, in 2017,
called the Syrian conflict
"the worst man-made disaster
the world has ever seen
since World War II."
The chart which I show you below
is really the change
in level of life satisfaction
in 163 countries,
blue being better life satisfaction,
red being worse.
And so you can see
that over this period of time,
life satisfaction in Syria
has declined significantly.
If we think about breast cancer in Syria,
in particular, these are
data from Global Can,
breast cancer, as many of you know,
remains the leading cause
of cancer in women worldwide,
and that is certainly the case in Syria.
It's also the leading cause of mortality.
And here you can see that
this is not just among women,
but breast cancer in Syria
is the leading malignancy,
period, across all genders
and the leading cause of
cancer-related mortality
across all genders.
So if we think about the map of Syria,
I highlighted here the capital,
Damascus, in red, which
you can see in the south,
Aleppo is a large city in the north,
and it was these two centers
that really had a lot of the healthcare,
especially prior to the conflict.
Where SAMS came in was
in establishing a clinic here in Idlib,
in the northwestern part of Syria,
where, as Kaveh mentioned,
this was really a conflict area.
And so the objectives of this study were
to understand the patient experience
and pathways to diagnosis of
patients with breast cancer
at the SAMS-supported
facilities in northwest Syria
and to evaluate factors
affecting stage at presentation
and outcomes of these patients.
So we did this with
both a qualitative study
as well as a quantitative one,
and I wanna walk you through
both parts of the study.
So for the qualitative study,
we set inclusion criteria
of patients who were
diagnosed with breast cancer
at the SAMS facilities who
were living in northwest Syria
who are at least 18 years of age or older.
90 patients were screened,
and 65 patients were excluded.
The reasons for the exclusions
were that 40 of them
did not have a working
telephone number or WhatsApp,
25 had either died or declined due
to current illness or lack
of incentive to participate,
and three could not find
a time to be interviewed
within the time period allotted.
So we were left with 22 patients
who were interviewed between August
and September of last year.
Informed consent was
taken by all participants.
This was a study that was approved
by the Yale Human
Investigations Committee.
The interviews were conducted
in conversational Arabic
in the local dialect, and
they were done on WhatsApp.
They were recorded,
transcribed, coded for themes.
NVivo software was used.
And they looked at a
framework analysis method
with a feminist lens.
Here are the demographics
of the participants.
So the mean age was 45
with a range of 24 to 67.
Roughly half, a little
less than half, 41%,
were internally displaced.
You can see that there were
no patients in this study,
where stage was known, who
had early-stage disease.
All of these patients had
either Stage II, III, or IV disease,
the majority of whom, over
50%, were Stage II and III.
18% were not educated.
Only 14% had a university education.
The majority of these women
had children and were married.
And the majority of them were working
as a housewife or were retired.
So that gives you a sense
of the population who were interviewed.
And as these interviews were conducted,
there were a number of
themes that emerged.
One was really this whole
idea of the challenges
in terms of accessing oncology care,
and many of the participants
were very grateful
to SAMS for having
established oncology care
in northwest Syria.
They mentioned things like the fact
that there was a center there,
actually reduced some of the challenges,
including cost of transport
and services in Turkey,
being away from family
and feeling isolated
because of the linguistic
barrier in Turkey,
delays in permission to cross the border,
and restrictions on companions.
Remember that many of these patients,
if they couldn't get care in Syria,
Turkey would be their alternative.
But that was not all roses.
There were transportation issues
within Syria too that were problematic.
Another issue that came up was
really the financial strain,
and I wanted to highlight
some of the quotes
that we got from participants
who were interviewed.
So participant number
eight, for example, said,
"We struggled a lot
because my husband doesn't
have a regular income.
One day he works and another he doesn't.
We are staying in tents,
and now because of the chemotherapy,
I feel too hot in the tent.
However, I try not to complain.
The living conditions are very difficult.
No one helps us with
the cost of treatment.
We had a freezer and refrigerator,
but we sold them so I can
continue my treatment."
And that gives you a
sense of what life is like
for many of these people living in Syria
in this conflict area and
the struggles that they face
in terms of the day-to-day living
as well as in affording
the cost of treatment.
There were also delays in care.
One of the things that I
should point out here is
that radiation therapy is not
available in northwest Syria,
and it's not available at
the SAMS Oncology Center
in northwest Syria either.
So for people who need radiation therapy,
the only option is to go to Turkey.
So participant number
one, for example, said,
"There is only one doctor
to see almost 200 patients a day
at the hospital that I was referred to."
She's talking here about the hospital
that she was referred to in Turkey.
She goes on to say, "One time
I stayed two months in Turkey
until my turn arrived, and by
that time, the doctor said,
'You will needs another
radiotherapy treatment.'"
And this was a recurring theme,
this idea of delays in
care being problematic
for these patients.
Another theme that came
out that was interesting
was in human relationships.
A couple of the participants noted
the real positive aspects
of their family
relationships that came out
during their cancer journey.
So participant number
13, for example, said,
"My husband did the impossible
and he left the family and
went with me to Turkey.
He never left me alone.
The amount of support I
got from him made me feel
that there is someone who really believes
that I can recover and survive.
This had an important role."
Participant number 17
had a similar experience.
She says, "My parents-in-law supported me,
and my husband, in particular,
helped me in Turkey as my
parents are not around.
He was the first one to
support me, thank God.
The emotional and psychological part
of this disease is important.
As long as you have someone
next to you supporting you,
you will forget about the disease,
and he was there next
to me all the the time."
And so we can see that for some patients,
they had incredibly strong family support,
which really helped them
to get through the breast cancer journey.
But it wasn't all good.
So participant 18, for example, said,
"Cancer wasn't as shocking for me
as when my husband left me.
You feel you are not useful
for anything anymore.
This is harder than the
disease, cancer, itself."
And he wasn't the only one.
So participant number four said,
"I have three children.
In the beginning, my
sister took care of my son
who was seven months old,
and the other children were
taken care of by my parents.
Then the community started
saying my husband needs
to marry again and have another wife
to take care of the children.
He did this and took the children,
so they are far away from me now."
And so you can see it's
not just the cancer journey
that many of these
patients had to deal with.
It was also some of the
human relationships,
the cultural relationships,
the family relationships
that they also had to contend with.
So that gave us a little bit of a taste
of what the experience
of these patients were
as they went through the
cancer journey in Syria.
The second part of this study
was really quantitative,
trying to get at,
what is the presentation
clinically of these patients,
how does that compare to
what we see here in the US,
and what factors really impact stage
at diagnosis, et cetera?
So in order to answer the
quantitative part of this project,
we review charts of
women who were diagnosed
with breast cancer at the
SAMS Oncology Center in Idlib
between 2018 and 2021.
So we looked at 192 patients.
The median age at diagnosis was 46
with a range between 22 and 80.
So just to put that into context, right,
if you think about the age at diagnosis
of breast cancer here in the US,
these are data that I'm showing you
from the American Cancer Society,
you can see that the median
age of diagnosis here is 62,
so a lot younger in terms of time,
date at diagnosis for patients in Syria.
Clinically, 16% of
these patients presented
with clinical distant metastatic disease.
70% had palpable lymph nodes
at the time of their presentation.
And at the time of surgery, 76% were found
to have pathologically-involved
lymph nodes.
And the median number of lymph nodes
that were found to be positive was four.
The invasive tumor size median
was four centimeters,
the range from 0.5 to 18 centimeters.
So for those of you who
may not be as familiar
with breast cancer and stage in the US,
just to put this into context,
and here, again, I'm showing
you the data from the ACS,
you can see here in the light pink bars,
across different races, distant
metastatic disease ranging
anywhere between 5 and 8%.
And you see that in Syria,
the rate of having
distant metastatic disease
was roughly double that.
And so we know that that
is certainly significant
prognosis of the patients
who have distant metastatic
disease is far inferior,
and, in fact, when people have
distant metastatic disease,
although the disease may be
treatable, it is not curable.
You can see in the medium pink bars
anywhere between 24 and 31%
of patients in the US will present
with what's called regional disease,
so lymph node-positive disease.
In Syria, again, more
than twice that at 76%.
And even when we have
patients here in the US
who have no positive disease, oftentimes,
that node positivity is
only one or two lymph nodes,
whereas in Syria, the median number
of lymph nodes involved was four.
In the US, many patients are presenting
with even pre-invasive cancers,
DCIS or Stage I.
Remember back to the qualitative
portion of the study,
where none of those patients
had that early-stage disease.
That's also reflected in
this quantitative analysis,
where the median size
was four centimeters.
So we're thinking more into that Stage II
to III breast cancer.
In terms of histology,
so of the 192 charts that we reviewed
where we had information about histology,
only three patients,
1.6%, present with DCIS.
DCIS is pre-invasive cancer,
essentially curable.
In the US, that number is about 17%.
In Syria, of the invasive breast cancers,
roughly 81% were invasive ductals.
13% were invasive lobular.
Those are similar to what
we see here in the US.
They had about 12% who
were triple negative.
That is to say that their tumors
did not express ER, PR,
or HER2 receptors on their surface.
The number in the US is roughly similar,
slightly lower, at 10%.
When we looked at how these patients
were diagnosed and treated,
you can see that 92%
had the diagnosis made
based on excision.
There's been now an
international consensus
that ideally we want to
diagnose these patients
using minimally-invasive techniques,
like needle biopsies,
usually a core needle biopsy.
And in Syria, only 4% of
the patients were diagnosed
based on core needle biopsy.
Now our analysis did not
get into why that was.
I can tell you based on experiences
that we've had in other
areas of the world,
for example, my brother does
a lot of work in global health
in Tajikistan, where core needle biopsies,
the actual device itself,
are just very hard to find.
There's just simply a lack of supplies.
And so that may have played
a role here, but, again,
we don't have information on that.
Despite these cancers being fairly large
and locally advanced at presentation,
where we here in the
West would have treated
those patients with chemotherapy first,
many of those patients
went on to receive surgery
as their initial treatment, 94% of them.
And again, further work needs to occur
to really dig into why that was.
It may have been the fact
that chemotherapy may
not have been available,
it may have been due to anxiety
on part of the patients,
or the fact that they were
facing fungating breast lesions,
where what we would call here
in the West a toilet mastectomy
or a palliative mastectomy, was required
simply to control the local disease.
Again, we do not have information
on the rationale behind these figure,
but rather this is more
hypothesis generating
rather than definitive.
What we do know is that they
had a very respectable time
between diagnosis and surgery.
A median of 15 days is
certainly acceptable
even here in the West,
but you can see that
that range was from zero,
perhaps by people who had
an excision of their cancer,
which was also curative at the same time,
all the way up to 756 days,
so that is more than two years,
which certainly is problematic.
We then looked at a number of
other interesting questions
that we were able to parse out
from the data that we collected.
One was exposure to chemical weapons.
Now in the analysis, in the
data that we had gathered,
only seven patients had
exposure to chemical weapons,
and so that's something
certainly to keep in mind.
These are small numbers,
and so, as you can see,
we did not achieve statistical
significance on the basis
of any of these clinical
pathologic factors,
but it may well have
been related to the fact
that we were comparing to
such a small sample size.
But if you look at the
actual numbers themselves,
you can see that those
who did have exposure to chemical weapons,
albeit that these are not
statistically significantly,
tended to be higher grade,
more often triple negative,
more often to have clinical
distant metastasis,
more often to be node positive,
more often to be larger in size,
which raises the question,
if we expanded this study,
wouldn't we in fact reach
statistical significance?
Again, hypothesis generating
rather than definitive.
The next question that we looked at was
seeing the difference between
citizens or host populations
and those who were internally displaced.
So here you can see
that in the cohort
charts that we looked at,
over half of these patients
were in fact displaced.
This goes back to the fact
that in the northwest Syria,
that is roughly the percentage
of the population who are displaced.
And you can see here that we found
no statistically significantly difference
in term of any of these
clinical pathologic factors,
which goes to say that people are people.
Whether you were displaced
or not displaced,
the type of breast cancer that we saw
amongst these two populations
were very similar.
You can look at the
individual parameters here,
and you can see that they're very similar.
One of the things that
was interesting, however,
when we looked at the differences
between the host population
and the internally displaced people
was that there was a trend,
albeit not a statistically
significant trend,
but still a trend with
the p-value of 0.051,
towards a shorter time from
diagnosis to the initiation
of treatment for internally
displaced people.
Now on the face of it, that
may seem counterintuitive.
You would think that those
who are internally displaced
would have a harder time accessing care,
they should have a
longer time to treatment,
but I think that there are a few things
to keep in mind here.
One is that, again, remember,
this may not truly be a
shorter time interval.
We did not hit statistical significance,
it's only a trend,
and it is still a relatively
small sample size.
However, the other thing that I think
that is important to keep in mind is
that these patients had
already accessed care.
They had already been
diagnosed with breast cancer
at the SAMS facility.
And so the ray of light here might be
that those people who were diagnosed
at the SAMS facility
in northwestern Syria,
it didn't seem to really impede
those who were internally displaced
in terms of getting their treatment.
If anything, their treatment
was slightly shorter,
14 days versus 19 days
from the time of diagnosis
than the host population, and
this may have been related
to other issues, right?
The host population might
have included citizens
who were employed, who might
have had other obligations
where it may have delayed them somewhat
in terms of getting their treatment.
Clinically, the difference
between 19 days and 14 days,
it is not terribly dramatic,
and so think it's at least reassuring
that internally displaced people,
once the diagnosis is
made, could get a treatment
in a relatively expeditious fashion.
So in summary, there are a number
of unique challenges faced
by breast cancer survivors
in northwestern Syria in
terms of access to care,
transportation, financial
strain, family tensions.
And when we look at
breast cancer in Syria,
at least in the
northwestern part of Syria,
in the SAMS Oncology Centers there,
the presentation tends to be younger women
at a higher stage, more
often triple negative,
more often diagnosed with excision
than what we would see here in the US.
Again, this study only
scratches the surface.
I think that there is still
plenty of work to be done.
If we compare those to who were exposed
to chemical weapons versus not,
there were no statistically
significant differences
in terms of clinical pathologic factors,
but there, again, I wonder whether that is
just related to the small sample size,
because when we look
at the actual numbers,
we do see differences
that may be meaningful.
But citizen or host populations
and those who were internally displaced
had very similar clinical
pathologic characteristics,
and at least for those who were treated
in the SAMS facility in
Idlib, it was no difference
in the time to treatment
between those populations.
If anything, there was a trend
to the internally displaced
population getting
a slightly shorter time interval
between diagnosis and treatment.
So this study would not have been possible
without a wealth of collaborators.
Kaveh mentioned how
this study got started.
Jude Alawa, who Kaveh mentioned,
should be on this slide,
so my apologies for that omission.
You can see here our SAMS colleagues
as well as a number of students at Yale
who participated in
making this work possible.
So I'm gonna stop there,
and I am happy to answer
any questions that you might have.
- Hi, I just have a general question.
So you mentioned about
the difference between,
no difference between cancer treatment
for people who are
internally displaced and
their host community.
I don't know if
with this SAMS,
do they collect also
information for other diseases?
Is that like something
that you see as well?
- Yeah, so our project only focused
on breast cancer patients, so
the charts that we reviewed
were all breast cancer patients.
I do know that the SAMS facility,
there does treat other
kinds of cancers and may,
although I'm not sure, and, Kaveh,
you might know better than me,
may also treat other diseases as well.
I know that they do treat other cancers,
but we did not look at that.
That might be something
for future study as well.
- Maybe I can ask a question
till there's a processing, I'm sure.
Thank you so much for that presentation,
and it's really, to my knowledge,
Syrian American Medical
Society's one of the few
international humanitarian organizations
that actually offers
cancer care and treatment.
I think there's a lot of
humanitarian organizations
that, for a variety of reasons,
don't see cancer care treatment as part
of their responsibilities.
I think Doctors Without
Borders, MSF does that.
So, of course, I'm
interested in figuring out,
how do we make this case
to other humanitarian
organizations that cancer care
and treatment is not something
that should be neglected?
Because the population
you're talking about,
they're stuck for decades.
So they don't just have
some acute, let's say,
infectious disease issues.
They have chronic conditions.
Cancer, of course, is one of them,
but I'm sure there's diabetes,
there's hypertension,
there's all kinds of NCDs, but in general,
humanitarian organizations
don't seem to focus
as much on NCDs as they ought to.
So I don't know if you have
any thoughts about that,
how do we make that case
that NCDs should become a priority
for humanitarian organization?
The other question I had was
on breast cancer prevention.
I'm just wondering if
there's any strategies
that can be done in reducing breast cancer
in displaced populations
in humanitarian setting.
- Yeah, so two very important questions.
The first one is really difficult, right?
Because we know,
particularly for cancer,
it's an expensive disease to treat.
It is an expensive disease to treat
because it requires a
multi-disciplinary effort.
It requires a lot of infrastructure.
It requires specialists.
And so for humanitarian organizations
who are trying to deliver care,
one can imagine that when they look
at their limited resources,
that they say to themselves,
"Where's the best place to spend our buck
and kind of get the biggest wins
that we can in the shortest
period of time that we can
for the least amount of money as we can?"
And so I think that that, therefore,
takes people into the route of,
"Well, let's make sure
that there's clean water.
Let's make sure that there's sanitation.
Let's make sure that we can feed children.
Let's make sure that we can
treat infectious diseases."
And those things are
important, but to your point,
as we see these conflicts
that are not limited in time,
that are extensive,
we know that the mortality associated
with noncommunicable diseases
is gonna far overtake
the mortality associated
with communicable diseases.
But I think that the
case is difficult to make
to these humanitarian organizations
because it is a big lift, right?
It is a lot of money to expend,
and particularly for things like cancer,
which is so complex,
you cannot think about
breast cancer being the same
as prostate cancer or lung cancer
or colon cancer or leukemia.
And so now you're treating
many different diseases.
It becomes difficult
to have the expertise,
the infrastructure, et cetera,
whereas other noncommunicable diseases,
heart disease, hypertension,
diabetes, might be easier.
And I think the last point that I'll make
is that the impact that you see,
many of these humanitarian organizations,
they want to see impact
because that's how they,
that's their life blood, right?
They are relying on funders.
They're relying on people,
philanthropic donations,
to fund their mission.
Part of the way that they
harness that is to say,
"Look at the impact that we're having."
And cancer is one of these where impact
is measured not in days but in years,
(chuckling) and it can take a
long time to see your impact.
And so I think those are the issues
that these humanitarian
organizations face.
I think one of the ways
to get over that is
to do a better job in terms
of taking care of the immediate issues
so that once those
immediate issues are done,
then these humanitarian
organizations can kinda say,
"Well, what else is there to do?"
and then work at the next issue,
which will be the
noncommunicable diseases.
Now this is not to say
that I don't think they
should do work in cancer,
this is my life blood, but I understand,
I understand the difficulty
that these NGOs face.
In terms of prevention,
this is another one that's hard, right?
Because if we think
about primary prevention,
which is really what I
think you're getting at,
how do you prevent the
disease from the first place,
it's really hard.
We think about primary
prevention and breast cancer,
reducing risk factors, well,
what are the two main risk factors
for developing breast cancer?
Being born female at
birth and getting older.
Like, what are you gonna do?
Family history plays in.
If we can avoid nuclear disasters,
radiation plays into breast cancer,
so if we can have world
peace, that might help.
But the modifiable risk factors are few.
And they're the ones that
everybody knows about, right?
So if you can reduce obesity,
increase physical activity,
maintain ideal body weight,
we know that you will reduce
your risk of many cancers,
and, P.S., you will also
reduce your risk of many NCDs
that are also key killers,
right, heart disease, diabetes,
stroke, et cetera, et cetera,
but we also know that our world population
is getting more and more obese.
So if we could do something on that front,
that potentially is a
very cost-effective way
of having a meaningful impact.
Will it have an impact that
will be measurable in days?
No, but it may have an impact
that will be measurable in years.
Other things, alcohol.
Well, okay, but
particularly in Middle East
with a large Muslim population,
that may not be as much of an issue
as it might be in Western countries.
Exogenous hormones, taking
hormone replacement therapy,
again, something that in
developing countries
may not be as prevalent
as it is here in the West.
Even here in the West,
we've seen that after
the Women's Health Initiative
study came out demonstrating
that exogenous hormones increase
the risk of breast cancer,
we saw that rate decline
and similarly saw a decline
in breast cancer instance.
But if we think about as a whole,
breast cancer is one of those
where there aren't a lot
of things we can do in
terms of primary prevention.
The other things is on
the family history side
and the genetics, we've
done studies, for example,
in Trinidad and Tobago, in Pakistan,
where we found a high prevalence
of triple negative breast
cancers in younger populations,
trying to see whether
they had a higher rate
of genetic mutations.
If they have a genetic mutation,
it doesn't mean that we now
magically can resolve this,
but women can do things
that will prophylactically
reduce their risk, right?
So you can do prophylactic mastectomies,
which will reduce your risk by 95%.
However, then you come
into the other problem,
which is in many of these areas,
in the Middle East, in Asia,
there are cultural stigmata
that play into this, right?
And so even patients who face
a diagnosis of breast cancer,
many of them will say,
"I was really scared to have treatment
because if I lost my breasts,
then I would not have been marriageable,
and if I was not marriageable,
then I would have been excluded
from the community," right?
And so the aspect of,
"Well, if we only knew the
genetics of the population,
we could take steps to
prophylactically reduce risk,"
also has problems, right?
So this is one of the things
that I always find challenging
about global health,
is that for everything
that you think of as a potential solution,
there are nine other problems that emerge.
It's kind of like this onion
that you keep peeling
the layers of the onion,
and there's still more layers underneath.
So Kaveh, you've had more experience
than me in this whole area.
What are your thoughts?
- Well, I mean, I developed
my Humanitarian Research Lab
because I want the
research to be beneficial
to humanitarian organizations
and policymakers.
I think that, to me, is a critical thing.
I'm so glad that you've
done this research,
and I'm really hopeful that SAMS is able
to use these evidence
and to apply for additional funds,
to get more support,
because now they have some data to share.
So that's really,
I feel like just bringing
some attention to this
and doing research that
humanitarian organizations
may not have the time or
the capacity to do that,
that's our role as an
academic institution.
- Yeah, and can I ask as well,
because these are areas
that are clearly from being affected
vastly by the conflict.
So how hard is for these institutions
that are able to give the
support to continue doing that?
Because, obviously, it's very different
if you are in a peaceful setting
and then to be able to plan ahead
rather than just trying to survive.
And then you were saying about,
I mean, all of the
diseases that they look at,
I mean, you would imagine
that probably trauma
will be one of the very first one
that they have to or they take care of,
both physically and
hopefully mentally as well.
- Yeah, yeah, no.
I think that SAMS
has been blessed
to have a reasonable philanthropic arm
that helps to fund some of its work,
and they are very committed
to really improving
particularly cancer care
in northwestern Syria.
But to your point, I think that we saw
that even SAMS facilities
had been embroiled in the conflict, right?
We know that the conflict had targeted
healthcare facilities,
and so it's really tragic
when you're trying to help populations,
and you're finding yourself
on the receiving end
of the conflict that
you're trying to help.
- And to the part of the cost,
they're able to provide all
of these services without any-
- Yeah, so they offer their
services free of charge,
but, again, I think that
they are very reliant
on donors and on
fundraising and on grants,
but, so far, my understanding is
that they do offer all of
this care free of charge.
Angie, I see your hand.
- [Angie] Hi, this is just terrific.
Thank you so much for sharing
and for doing such important work.
I have a question more around methods,
and I love how you have triangulated.
You looked the epidemiology of it.
You have thought of the possibilities
of the molecular genetics of it,
but you've also done some of
the qualitative work around it.
So I love, I love the way
that you are truly approaching this
from mixed-method approach.
Can you take a little bit about
what the qualitative process looked like?
Was this mostly looking
for emergent themes
in the experiences of women
or did you come in with a priori,
maybes ideas or assumptions
of what was highly relevant to them?
And then the second part
to that question is,
what does sort of
the Syrian academic engagement look like?
What potential, what role do you see there
in kind of complex public
health questions like this one?
Thank you.
- Yeah.
So, full disclosure, I was
not directly participating
in the qualitative portion.
This was really done by our
colleagues through SAMS.
My Arabic is much worse than their English
(chuckles) 'cause my Arabic
is pretty much non-existent.
But my understanding is
that the interviews were conducted
without any necessarily a priori
understanding of themes that would emerge,
but really those are themes that came out
of the conversations as they occurred.
The researchers who had much more
than experiencing qualitative
research than I did
kind of applied this framework methods
to the interviews that they got,
used NVivo to help code for themes,
had consultation between investigators
to really parse out what were the themes
that were emerging and
kind of went from there.
In terms of the second question,
academic partnerships,
I think that this is still emerging.
So this was the first project
that I had done with SAMS.
They have researchers
both located within Syria,
at the university there,
as well as in the UK and in the US.
And so we were able to
kind of partner together
in a transnational way to answer questions
that were important to all parties.
Kaveh, I don't know if
you wanna add anything.
- I think you covered
what I was thinking about.
I was also thinking about how we were,
I know you were particularly interested
in trying to hire Syrian medical students
in northwest Syria to participate in this.
There was a lot of policy issues
around being able to
fund students in Syria,
so that was a bit challenging,
but we somehow still managed.
It took a couple of months to figure out
how to do the qualitative work, but, yeah.
- Yeah, and to that point, Angie,
I think that Kaveh brings up a good point,
is there are regulations
between what can pass
between the US and Syria
because of embargoes,
and so on, and so forth.
We complied with that, right?
There are rules that you have
to color within the lines,
but hopefully you can still collaborate
and find interesting
ways that you can partner
to answer important questions.
- [Angie] Wonderful, thank
you. Thank you so much.
- Thank you, everybody, for joining us,
especially Angie from Bhutan.
So glad to see you.
Angie has done some wonderful work
on early child development in Lebanon
and in many other countries,
so thanks for joining us.
Dr. Chagpar, thank you so much.
This was incredible,
and I really hope that this
research will make a difference
for the Syrian population who
are struggling with cancer
and many other issues, so thank you.
- All right, thanks, everyone. Take care.
Have a great day.
- Later. Bye bye.
- Thank you very much for
the presentation excellence.
- Thank you, Teresa. Bye bye.